I want to spend the rest of my life with  you  me  congratulations to Ben Higgins and his  new fiancee Lauren Bushnell after weeks  of anticipation and then telling both  Jojo and Lauren B he loves them I am  completely in love with you  I've known I'm in love with you for a  while as well he finally made his  decision on tonight's finale of The  Bachelor Higgins even called the 25-year  old flight attendants father to ask for  her hand in marriage mr. Bush now says  Ben Higgins I would like to ask you for  your daughter's hand in marriage  newly engaged couple made their debut on  after the final rose where they gushed  over their romance and what to expect  next have you guys talked about a  wedding we've discussed yeah I mean I  don't want a long engagement I know I am  ready to marry him so